we're having a look at asymptotes
because of these kinds of asymptotes
because there are really easy asset to
us we know how to work with for example
there are vertical asymptotes these the
easiest to spot both of these functions
have vertical asymptotes let's have a
look at left hand one what's its
vertical asymptote it has it has a
single vertical asymptote where is it
it's gonna be at X do it be a little
more specific than just the number
because of course it's a line right so
it's it's x equals zero where the
denominator is zero you're in trouble
okay so you have a single one for this
one this is gonna have two where are the
vertical assets for this guy are gonna
be x equals plus and minus one okay so
we know how to fight vertical asymptotes
well so quite good at working out where
horizontal asymptotes are so this one on
the right hand side has a horizontal
asymptote can you help me work out what
it is this horizontal asymptote is going
to be not just here but y equals zero
because it's actually a line okay so we
know that because there's a bunch of
different ways you can think about this
right actually you told me how did you
reason through knowing that this would
have a horizontal asymptote let's start
drawing this thing by the way how did we
know that it was going to have it that's
a really not horizontal a horizontal
asymptote of y okay so one way you can
think about this is to look at the
powers right look at the powers so the
denominators power is with the biggest
powers to and the biggest one up here is
one so as X gets bigger and bigger and
bigger because that's what horizontal
asymptotes are about like the edges the
extremities as X gets huge the numerator
gets huge but the denarian will always
get huge ah that's the technical term
okay so this guy the denominator takes
over right does that make sense so since
the denominator takes over it's going to
get much bigger so the whole thing is
going toward zero so that's fine let's
put on y equals zero on two here so this
that's fine okay when you have a look at
this it's not happening right you don't
get the denominator taking over it
doesn't go to just x equals y equals
zero or a simple number or something
like that
so we'll come back to this guy in a
minute let's just quickly draw this
we'll do the quick and dirty version
I'm you're ready told me about the
vertical asymptote so let's put those
guys in I've got y equals zero here
let's call this x equals negative 1 and
x equals positive 1 now you kind of
because I've given to you a fairly easy
function you've probably sort of
factorized in your brain so this
denominator here what happens to it when
I factorize it well I get
I only take it carefully it's going to
be a difference of squares right it's
gonna be different
and this is actually the reason why some
of you who solve it before I actually
wrote down X we have minus 1 the first
time and then I realize actually
something important I want to point out
here so 1 minus X 1 plus X is the
difference of squares not to be confused
with X minus 1 X plus 1 because of
course the order is different right the
minus signs in a different spot and this
will become important for us when we do
one of our steps here we've factorized
we've already got all the asymptotes is
there an intercept
are there any intercepts this is going
to pass through now I you need to tell
me more than 0 because I haven't asked
for a specific kind of intercept all
right so are you telling me x equals 0 y
equals 0 which one vada rhetorical
question is that x equals 0 or y equals
0 and the answer is it's both right it
goes through the origin when x equals 0
I don't care what the denominator is
y is also going to be 0 so I'm gonna put
that there
okay since I am going through the origin
I'm their noble intercepts to find so
now I'm up to the regions step ok now
this region step is a bit tricky a lot
of people maybe have missed the fact
that the things you're drawing the lines
you're about to draw on exactly
correspond
the factors that you have there right
now some of these are very easy to draw
X for example I know exactly what that
looks like there's no y equals x factor
X plus 1 or 1 plus X is also easy to
draw it looks like this mm-hmm there you
go but 1 minus X even though the rest of
these lines go like this right 1 minus X
does not go like this because 1 minus X
doesn't have a gradient like these
what's the gradient of 1 minus X its
negative 1 so it's actually going down
right so this you can see I'd you that's
1 minus X right and that's kind of a big
deal having a going in that direction
because it changes how our factors
behave right for instance over over here
on the left hand side which is where I'm
going to be it's always where I start
you're used to saying oh there's three
factors and they'll all start off
negative yeah but clearly all three
factors are not negative over here right
I've got positive negative negative so
when you put it together what do you get
a positive okay as I cross over this
factor
what's this factor it's a 1 plus X
Factor it changes sign so now I'm going
positive positive negative which means
negative okay let's see here in this
little small region here I've got
positive positive positive yeah so it's
still doing it's still switching around
it's just switching around in a
different way then if that line was
going in the opposite direction yeah
what's my last one positive positive
negative so I end up down here cool okay
I've got all the information I need I
can draw this thing right I could have
used calculus but as you'll see in a
second I don't need it have a look on
the left-hand side what do you think is
going to happen how would you describe
it it sort of looks like the branch of a
hyperbola right because look you've got
two asymptotes you sort of stuck between
them and the region also sticks you up
there you can't go anywhere else
so therefore OOP there you go that looks
fine now have a look at this middle
section in here between the two vertical
asymptotes you've got to pass through
the origin there you're going to go from
negative to positive what's it going to
do
how would you describe it yes there's
going to be a point of inflection here
isn't there right it has to be a point
of inflection we actually knew that this
is the shape before we even had a
language for point of inflection because
otherwise you can't approach those
asymptotes properly right does that make
sense it can't be concave down because
then it would just blow straight through
the asset oh that's not what it's
supposed to do and then the last section
over here happy times okay does that
look all right you okay with that